madame monsieur bonjour bienvenue dans
son caddie nouvelle saison qui fait
aujourd'hui sa rentrée une émission que
j'aurai le plaisir de présenter en
alternance avec bertrand caruge pour
cette première de la saison nous
parlerons de la rentrée scolaire avec
notre invité valérie vertal loriot
bonjour bonjour monsieur livory vous
êtes au secrétaire académique du snes
fsu
l'année scolaire s'est terminée par une
mobilisation des enseignants avec la
rétention des copies du bac
aujourd'hui la situation n'est pas
apaisée comment pourriez vous qualifier
cette rentrée 2019 2020
alors on a l'impression d'une rentrée
quand même assez morose parce que les
collègues se rappelle de ce qui s'est
passé à la fin de l'année avec des avis
différents sur ce qui s'est passé à la
fin de l'année mais surtout avec une
volonté de se faire entendre par le
ministre on s'est quittés aussi avec
beaucoup de mépris de ce ministre
beaucoup de mots qui ont été accueillis
extrêmement difficilement par l'ensemble
de nos collègues et aujourd'hui nous
attendons de voir mais nous sommes aussi
extrêmement inquiète de tout ce qui se
met en place parce qu'il ya tout un
ensemble des réformes un rythme effréné
et notamment la réforme des lycées et du
justement nous allons en parler dans
votre collimateur aujourd'hui la réforme
des lycées celle du bac
qu'est ce qui vous gêne exactement il ya
tellement de choses qui nous gêne dans
cette réforme déjà à l'absence de
concertation parce que on fait semblant
d'avoir concertée l'ensemble des
organisations syndicales
alors que le projet était déjà tout
ficelé mais c'est surtout la suppression
des filières ont fait semblant de
supprimer les filières et on se rend
compte avec le choix des élèves puisque
vous savez que les seconds ont choisi
leur spécialité pour cette année en
classe de première on se rend compte
qu'on fait semblant de proposer des
choix particulier en fonction des
appétences de chacun des élèves et que
finalement les familles reprennent les
filières et en général ce sont les
familles aux catégories
socioprofessionnelles les plus
autun qui recrée définir et notamment la
filière s on voit dans cette académie
que ce que ça vaut 100 des élèves ont
choisi les mathématiques que ce que les
familles regrette flir qu'est ce que
vous entendez par là et ça veut dire que
beaucoup de familles choisissent par
exemple ce pour celle qui faisait au
départ les filières est la filière s ils
choisissent comme spécialité maths
physique svt pour celle qui faisait s
ils choisissent maths et s c'est à dire
l'économie les filières sont recréés
sauf pour les on se rend compte aussi
que les catégories socioprofessionnelles
les plus défavorisés celles qui sont les
plus éloignés de l'école font des choix
assez baroque qui ne vaut correspondre
m'a malheureusement à rien pour le
supérieur
et quand on voit ce qu'ils sortent déjà
du supérieur comme prévisions ils disent
beaucoup aux familles de choisir à ben
l'ancien filière est c'est-à-dire maths
physique et svt
on se rend compte que certaines certains
élèves qui ont fait les choix les plus
baroques seront certainement défavorisé
pour parcours super que nous ce contre
lequel on se bat depuis un certain
nombre de temps déjà
cette réforme crée des inégalités selon
lui tout à fait il y as énormément des
neg alité qui seront créés par cette
réforme déjà par le choix défi d'aider
des spécialités par les élèves mais
aussi et surtout par les difficultés que
vont avoir certains à réussir dans
parcours sup mais aussi par tout ce qui
se passe au niveau des choix par conçu
pour va y revenir mais la mise en réseau
des établissements scolaires est ce que
ça va pas favoriser la réussite des
élèves alors au départ c'est ce que le
ministre voulait qu'il y à une mise en
réseau des établissements pour pouvoir
permettre à la plupart des élèves de
faire l'ensemble des spécialités et de
fer ont je crois sur l'ensemble des
spécialités
finalement avec la mise en oeuvre de ces
réseaux on se rend compte et les chefs
d'établissement se sont rendu compte de
la difficulté immense qu'il y avait à
faire à faire ce choix des réseaux mais
la chose et que c'est encore pire
on est une des rares zacademy avoir à
avoir continué cette mise en réseau
puisque c'est aix marseille et la
martinique seulement qui sont dans les
réseaux moi j'avoue je vais donner quand
même un exemple c'est quand même assez
un faux lent qu'aujourd'hui les élèves
de ducos enfin du réseau du sud ne
savent toujours pas comment ils seront
acheminés vers le marin vers rivière
salée c'est à cette heure ils ne savent
toujours pas et les familles sont
vraiment dans l'impossibilité de
s'organiser pour pouvoir acheminer leurs
enfants vers le lycée de rivière salée
ou le lycée de ducos ou le lycée du
marin pour pouvoir faire la spécialité
qu'ils ont choisi donc c'est encore de
l'esbrouffe tout simplement parce qu' on
essaie de mettre en place quelque chose
je comprends de vouloir essayer de
mettre en place quelque chose cependant
la mise en oeuvre n'est pas facile et ce
sont encore des difficultés les élèves
ne vont pas choisir les disciplines qui
ne sont pas enseignées dans leur
établissement
mais quand même 7 cette réforme est
quand même nécessaire le niveau des
élèves chute dans les matières
fondamentales et le niveau du bape
également est le reflet le niveau du bac
est le reflet de celui des élèves
il fallait quand même faire quelque
chose le snes ne dis pas qu'il ne faut
pas de réforme nous avons un certain
nombre d'idées sur les réformes qu'il
faudrait faire pour tenter de relever le
niveau
cependant cette réforme là qui est une
réforme et on le dit en l'assument qui
tue qui fait uniquement dans le but de
supprimer des postes encore et ben n'est
pas la bonne tout simplement parce que
justement elle va encore mettre en place
des inégalités au sein des élèves et je
ne crois pas que le but est de
l'éducation nationale et j'en suis
persuadé qu'il ne s'agisse pas de ça
pour l'éducation nationale qu'il y ait
plus d'inégalités mais aujourd'hui quand
on aura des bacs maison le bac de frantz
fanon le bac de schoelcher le bac de
bellevue vous imaginez bien qu'il va
compter bien moins dans parcours sub que
le bac sur le territoire national vous
êtes en train de dire que par exemple le
contrôle continu pour le bape ne va pas
produire d'effets ne sera pas relevée
le niveau des élèves pas du tout ça va
pas relever le niveau des élèves et le
problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est la
première année que nous ne serons pas en
mesure de répondre à des questions à des
familles ça veut dire que les choses
sont tellement incertaine elles ont
tellement été décidée dans la rapidité
juste pour mettre son nom est apposé son
nom sur une réforme qu'on est dans
l'incapacité d'expliquer aux familles
véritablement ce qui va être mis en
place
le contrôle continu à partir de janvier
on sait que c'est à partir de janvier on
sait que c'est peut-être en mai les
deuxièmes on n'a aucune assurance
aujourd'hui aucune visibilité sérieux de
la part de ministères que de mettre en
place une réforme pour laquelle en
septembre on a des sujets 0 qui ne
correspondent pas véritablement un grand
chose dans laquelle nous n'avons pas
encore de calendrier dans laquelle on ne
sait même pas quel professeur seront
convoqués aux différentes commissions et
dans laquelle on sait déjà qu'il y aura
une désorganisation monstrueuse de
l'année scolaire puisqu'il faudra
organiser les épreuves de contrôle
continu je trouve que sincèrement et au
snes nous trouvons que ce n'est pas
sérieux de la part de ministres vous
dire également la sonnette d'alerme
d'alarmé concernant la suppression de 95
postes dans l'académie
oui ces dernières années si près plus de
1000 postes qui ont été supprimés dans
cette académie on fragilise une académie
avec des difficultés au départ puisque
nous sommes une académie avec des
difficultés avec des quatre rigoriste
socioprofessionnelles plus défavorisés
un tonneau familles monoparentales plus
important qu'ailleurs
et aujourd'hui on fragilise une académie
on fragilise des jeunes qui passent en
concours et qui sont envoyées dans les
académies
française c'est-à-dire paris créteil
versailles qui sont nos académies
d'extension on fragilise cette académie
alors que on sait qu'on a besoin
d'enseignants et on a bien vu qu'il a
fallu reconsidérer un certain nombre de
décisions qui avaient été prises par le
rectorat au mois de février
parce que tout simplement on prend
l'exemple du collège de ducos qui a dû
se battre pour pouvoir avoir des moyens
supplémentaires à l'anc alors qu'ils
n'ont strictement aucune baisse
démographique dans leur établissement
nous ne revenons pas en cause sur la
baisse démographique certes il ya une
baisse démographique dans dans cette
académie mais pour nous c'est le moment
de maintenir nos enseignants pour
pouvoir travailler de manière beaucoup
plus différenciant avec nos élèves
eu égard à nos difficultés d'être 2000
élèves en moins sur le tennis que même
une ombre alors oui on peut dire qu'il y
à des élèves en moins sur cette académie
cependant quand on supprime une classe à
chaque fois qu'il ya quinze élèves de
moisson trouve ça assez scandaleux parce
que les classes ici non pas 15 élèves
autre autre combat que vous menez au
niveau des contrats aidés et là le
recteur est clair en 2020 on aura plus
alors oui on a eu peur pour cette année
on a eu peur qu'il soit entièrement
supprimée mais il faut on se rappelle
quand même la lutte que l'on nous avions
mené cela fait deux ans on avait obtenu
une 920 contrats aidés il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui on en est à cinq cent
soixante trois mois j'ai eu mes cpe et
notamment ce matin je les ai eus avant
de venir qui me disent que les choses
sont extrêmement graves dans les vie
scolaire qu'il n'y a pas suffisamment de
moyens parce que sur les 563 contrats
aidés qui sont donnés à ceux affectés à
cette académie la plupart sont dans le
premier degré pour les directeurs
d'école parce que c'est aussi une charge
qui est importante mais aussi il y avait
une autre partie qui est essentiellement
affectés aux élèves handicapés
ce qui est aussi quelque chose de
fondamental cependant pour l'ebit
scolaire ses livres ce sont les bus
scolaires du second degré qui paye le
plus lourd tribut puisque nous n'avons
pratiquement aucun contrat dans nos vies
scolaires les cpe sont extrêmement
inquiets et bientôt nous allons les
réunir pour pouvoir faire le point avec
eux
on attend que la rentrée se passe pour
faire le point avec eux pour savoir ce
qu'il est en mesure de faire parce que
nous n'accepterons pas de mettre nos
élèves martinique est en danger dans les
établissements scolaires des
mobilisations à prévoir dans ce cadre
des contrats aidés encore une nouvelle
fois alors pour l'instant nous ne savons
strictement rien nous attendons parce
que nous sommes aussi une organisation
syndicale qui fait attention à au nombre
d'heures qu'ils sont donnés à nos élèves
on n'a pas envie de rentrer encore dans
une confrontation dure comme ça s'est
passé il y a deux ans
cependant nous n'hésiterons pas à nous
mobiliser si nos élèves martiniquais
sont en danger dans les établissements
scolaires nous n'hésiterons pas nous
sommes une organisation syndicale
responsable
alors madame verdalle loriot est plus
que la réforme ce que ce n'est pas le
manque de reconnaissance de votre
hiérarchie qui pose problème
bien sûr qu'il ya aussi un manque de
reconnaissance de notre hiérarchie mais
nous allons plus loin il ya un mépris de
notre hiérarchie pour le travail au
quotidien vous savez avec cette réforme
qui a été mise en place au lycée il ya
de nouvelles disciplines il y à aussi de
deux nouveaux programmes
tous les jours on entend un certain
nombre de personnes se plaindre des
vacances des enseignants et vous il faut
savoir que 90 % des vacances ont été
gardés pour pouvoir mettre en place ces
nouvelles réformes
ces nouveaux programmes il faut savoir
que des enseignants sont des personnels
responsables eux qui doivent repenser
leur manière d'enseigner le média logis
les méthodes pédagogiques et toutes les
méthodes les méthodes pédagogiques qu'on
en parle aussi à quel moyen à quel
moment excusez moi le ministère met en
place des moyens pour que nous puissions
nous former sur la méthodologie
aujourd'hui on nous parle de de faire
des stages hors du temps scolaire alors
que dans toutes les professions
les stages sont effectués sur le temps
de travail c'est inadmissible et oui
nous manquons de reconnaissance et je
crois que aujourd'hui les collègues en
ont assez d'être méprisés par leur
hiérarchie les emplois du temps sont une
catastrophe avec cette réforme puisqu'il
faut aligner des enseignements de
spécialité
ce n'est pas acceptable que nos
enseignants se sentent mal
il y aussi la rémunération il y a aussi
réuni 300 euros en 2020 selon une année
c'est pas suffisant selon vous c'est
honteux que le ministère aujourd'hui que
monsieur le ministre présente une
augmentation des salaires qui avait été
prévu par le gouvernement hollandais
qu'ils se sont dépêchés dès leur arrivée
de repousser d'un an
c'est honteux quand on réfléchit et
quand on fait les calculs ces 300 euros
beaucoup de personnes pensent que ces
300 euros par mois
pas du tout c'est 300 euros par an ce
qui correspond correspond à 25 euros par
mois
brute nette 19 euros vous trouvez qu'il
s'agisse d'une augmentation d'une
rémunération
il s'agit de mépris les collègues
considèrent aujourd'hui qu'on les
méprise et qui ne sont pas reconnus à
leur juste valeur on arrive à la fin de
notre interview si vous deviez faire une
bonne proposition aujourd'hui au recteur
de l'académie
quelle serait cette proposition alors
monsieur le recteur de droit absolument
entendre le malaise des collègues il y a
énormément de risques psychosociaux au
sein de cette académie notamment il faut
absolument que les collègues aujourd'hui
soient reconnus dans leur métier au
niveau de leur chef d'établissement mais
aussi au niveau du rectorat
quand on voit les conditions dans
lesquelles les collègues ont été nommés
sur des postes
les dernières commissions ont eu lieu le
26 juillet ce n'est pas acceptable
madame verdalle loriot merci bonne
journée à l'écouté de nos programmes
[Musique]